he's uh you darvish's new routine he
likes to come out and
yeah get ready and then he'll at one
point tell his teammates come on out
now mike freeman playing at second base
tonight left-handed hitter
swing and a miss strike three the ball
in the dirt so carratini has to throw to
first and
does and that's out number two fellow
right-hander carlos carrasco going for
the indians he's two and four with a
3.12
era and the cubs beat him on august 12th
chris bryant having a disappointing year
batting 200 couple of homers four rbis
he's played with a sore left wrist
now the o2 and it swung on him missed he
chased
a breaking ball in the left-handed
hitters batters box
here's baez down to the sixth spot
a drive out in the center well
one to nothing get out the tape measure
for
javier baez cubs lead one to nothing
a booming home run to dead center
and the cubs have the lead here in the
second inning
here's delino de shields the shields at
2 47 average boy is
rizzo in close at first he's 60 feet
from the plate and moving in
the pitch and it's punted third base
side and a beauty bryant barehan grab
throw to first
it's wide of the mark on his way home to
scores
naylor into second is to shields he'll
make the turn he'll go to third to throw
the slide the tag
safe at third as darvish took the throw
oh what a bunt down the third base line
lindor batting left-handed game tied at
one
go ahead run at third nobody out here in
the third inning
the set by darvish and the one-two pitch
to lindor
and he swings and lines the base hit to
left field
the indians take the lead lindor a big
turn he'll go to second
schwarber having trouble getting to the
ball he picked it dropped it but it
wouldn't have mattered
and rbi doubled down the left field line
by francisco lindor
and the cubs will bring the infield in
against jose ramirez
ramirez in the air lindor ready to tag
this should be fun hayward cranks it up
[Music]
what a throw jason hayward
the gold glover two ounce two on for
jason
kempness here's the pitch to him swung
on and there's a high fly ball to left
near the line moving over
naylor and he makes the catch in fair
territory
to retire kipnis and the cubs in the
fourth
now it's back to the top of the lineup
for francisco lindor
up the middle and through around third
the shields will score
and the indians add to their lead
francisco lindor
has driven and run for the second time
tonight
so there's two down in the inning and
jose ramirez will bat
now sets and delivers the pitch ground
ball right side
baez fields it tosses to first
and the side is retired for cleveland
but not before the indians push another
run
across home plate hap at second base
chris bryant at the plate
that'll be a base hit great read by half
here's a throw toward the plate it's air
[Music]
and he will stay there it's three to two
so the tying run on second base in
bryant anthony rizzo at the plate
rizzo out into center the shields again
it's gonna have to play this one
out of the envy brian is in we're tied
three to three third base two down for
kyle schwarber
now the o2 swung on popped him up
shallow right coming on naquin and tyler
and aquin makes the catch to retire the
side
one down here in the sixth dunning
here's fran mio reyes he has
punched out twice
right field here comes hayward
and it's rizzo
territory anthony rizzo with a beautiful
grab
and roberto perez hitless in his last 10
at bats coming to the plate
perez a slightly open stance in the 1-2
pitch
swing and a miss strike three darvish
gets the strikeout
and jose ramirez 0 for three on the
night but he will get a chance
to break the tie the pitch to jose
ramirez is
hit in the air left center playable for
ian happ he's there he's got it
you darvish gets the biggest out
that he has gotten in this game the
cleanup hitter wilson contreras coming
up
and the pitch on the way fly ball right
center field it should be deep enough
it's definitely deep enough out near the
track tagging as bryant
the catch by nate one bryant scores
cobb's lead
wilson contreras gets the job done
that'll bring up the number seven here
jason hayward had
maybe the defensive turnaround play of
the night
there goes baez the pitch swung on and
missed throw to second bad throw goes to
setter baez goes to third
and by his rounding third he's going to
try to score here comes the throw to the
plate
offline he scores javier baez
kept on going he scores all the way from
first
one away here's lindor
glendor drives one deep left field back
on the track is happy's up
and it's gone it's a game-tying home run
for francisco lindor oh he went the
other way
stayed on it and drove it out of here to
tie the game
his eighth home run of the season
and he's driven in four runs on the
night here comes cameron maven where the
bases loaded
with home cubs win
can you believe it he
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very good ball game